man it's even better on the 15th read oh
hello i didn't see you there dear
viewers of scp explained i'm on break
between supervising scp-682 termination
attempts and inspecting the mops we use
on
scp-173's leavings so i decided to do
what all the cool people are doing in
their spare time right now rereading
chainsaw man the hit manga by japanese
author and artist tatsuki fujimoto for
the uninitiated it's the story of denji
a poor young man from japan who makes
his living hunting devils dangerous
creatures that are embodiments of
mankind's greatest fears but when that
living leads to him dying at the hands
of a gang of zombie yakuza believe me it
makes sense in context he bonds with the
legendary chainsaw devil and is reborn
as chainsaw man an unconventional
superhero who chainsaws first and asks
questions later naturally i was eager to
see how one of our own bloodthirsty
killers would fare against dengi's
chainsaws of fury so i selected the most
violent battle-hardened and
carnage-hungry anomaly out there
scp-076-2 the immortal warrior known as
abel the two of them have a surprising
amount of things in common both are
effectively immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical
injuries both absolutely love to fight
with their array of deadly weapons and
anomalous strength both have been part
of experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of japan's public
safety devil hunters division four and
abel being an ex-member of the scp
foundation's disastrous pandora's box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect matchup so after
forcing the trusty anomatron 6000 to
read every currently available volume of
chainsaw man and compute years of able's
gruesome battle data i've set up the
perfect simulation for your viewing
pleasure and hey fellow fans of the
manga isn't it horrifying that even we
beat mappa to the punch of animating
this thing
ah god that joke will age poorly if that
anime comes out before this anyway let's
crank this machine into action and let
her rip japan 1997
everything is roasting in the july heat
men in black harrison ford's air force
one and airbud are hitting theaters for
the first time everything is right with
the world that's why over in the
headquarters of the public safety devil
hunting department denji our chainsaw
loving hero is being praised by his kind
boss and mentor figure makima a lovable
supportive woman who will never do
anything wrong she even loves dogs how
could a person who loves dogs ever be
evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he'd managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say makima was
extremely pleased with denji's work here
but now she had considerably more graver
news to impart she'd gotten word from an
envoy of another organization that hunts
down dangerous and anomalous creatures
the scp foundation that an extremely
lethal entity had breached their
containment and was now somewhere in
japan the entity in question was not a
devil and thereby would be working on a
different rule set makima opened a file
faxed to her by the foundation yes
remember this is set in 1997 and gave
dengi the crucial lowdown several hours
ago the entity known as abel had
resurrected from his huge black
sarcophagus in the underwater chamber of
the classified facility containment area
25b after waking up abel had slaughtered
his way through the entire base killing
every scp foundation operative in his
path and then swimming out into the
pacific ocean sometime after that he
infiltrated a japanese cargo ship and
murdered all the workers on board before
steering the ship back towards the land
of the rising sun where he hoped to
claim even more victims makima told
denji that it would fall to him and his
associates to stop this able with a
little help from the scp foundation's
intelligence but be warned abel is an
incredible combatant with extreme
physical strength and durability as well
as surprising tactical intelligence it
wouldn't be an easy fight but makima
promised that if denji won she'd hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him
denji replied consider him dead already
miss makima meanwhile abel was walking
through the slums of tokyo marveling at
the neon signs for bars and clubs his
journey to japan hadn't been an accident
abel had been to japan once before in
the year
1605. he'd face the legendary japanese
philosopher and swordsman miato musashi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history abel
had dueled musashi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harima province where after a tense
battle musashi cut him down abel would
not resurrect again during musashi's
lifetime but the battle gave him a deep
and abiding respect for the legendary
warrior abel knew that if the
opportunity ever rose again he would
return to japan in hopes of experiencing
such a brilliant battle yet again but
the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much it was no longer the
quiet and pastoral japan he'd
experienced but a booming epicenter of
trade and commerce he found it all
strange and perplexing suddenly he found
himself surrounded by a group of
japanese street thugs many of them
wielding switchblades they laughed at
his strange outfit which to them looked
like an old worn bed sheet one of the
smarter members of the group had already
decided to go home when the others made
up their mind to mug abel the warrior's
extensive tattoos made him look like a
middle eastern yakuza dawn the rest
however were happy to take their chances
with him empty your pockets if that
goofy toga even has pockets the leader
said holding up his switchblade unless
you want to get cut abel just smirked
and drew a pair of long obsidian daggers
in the following moment the alley was
filled with screams then was silent yet
again abel walked on breathing a sigh of
disappointment at how incredibly
mediocre this first fight had been his
blades dripping with fresh blood musashi
is rolling in his grave abel thought to
himself meanwhile across town denji and
the rest of division four were
mobilizing it was him the serious
sword-wielding aki and the adorable
pathologically lying blood-fiend power
they'd been told over the phone by a man
named dr bright that able would be
relatively easy to track down he's not
known for his subtlety all you need to
do is follow the trail of carnage he
causes wherever he goes from the way he
talks about him it seems almost as
though dr bright bears a personal grudge
against abel how strange power didn't
seem intimidated she proudly proclaimed
i don't think this battle will be
difficult at all
in fact i've faced this abel before and
defeated him handily
aki sighed and asked when did this
happen
last tuesday
of course
she replied power had only heard about
abel this morning but denji and aki had
learned better than to dispute her at
this point suddenly a large television
screen that had been previously relaying
an ad for a cutting-edge stereo system
cut to an emergency news report there
had been a horrific incident in downtown
tokyo where a bar had been attacked and
most of its patrons murdered by a
deranged tattooed man carrying a pair of
huge swords aki immediately recognized
this place the bar was yakuza owned if
this able was on the hunt for worthy
opponents it makes all the sense in the
world that japan's iconic crime
syndicates would be his first target
denji aki and power knew exactly where
they needed to go over at the bar abel
was having a whale of a time innocent
patrons were running and screaming while
the yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with a terrifying inhuman warrior
several of them had already been cut
down two yakuza soldiers behind the bar
were reloading illegal oozies and
preparing to return fire both were
sweating terrified by the sudden random
attack when they'd shot him before he'd
managed to dodge most of the bullets and
expertly blocked the rest with his
swords who the hell had sent this
monster was he with the triads the
russian mob or some devil summoned by
the japanese government to crack down on
them whatever the case he seemed almost
impossible to kill the two men stood
back up and opened fire abel held his
two swords and spun like a propeller
blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly he then produced another
dagger seemingly from thin air and threw
it directly into the heart of one of the
two remaining yakuza behind the bar he
dropped to the ground dead instantly
leaving only his friend alive in a bar
full of corpses that's when abel noticed
a decorative katana behind the bar he
smiled and ordered the surviving yakuza
soldier to pick up the sword and give
him a real fight the hapless mobster
realized in that moment that this guy
was truly crazy whoever he was but what
choice did he have now with tara and his
heart the last surviving yakuza grabbed
the katana and unsheathed it good
abel said his voice deep and menacing
now
come fight me let's see if you last a
few seconds longer than your worthless
friends shall we
he did not the second the yakuza ran
towards abel and the ancient swordsmen
swiped at him with one of his blades
cutting through the katana and the
opponent holding it a puny gangster
never stood a chance against a deadly
immortal warrior and abel was furious
the last time he was here he faced a
truly expert killer who even managed to
end abel's life in a single combat and
now he was slaying insects in a karaoke
bar pathetic suddenly his ears picked up
he turned to see a red axe flying at his
head at incredible speeds with his
superhuman reflexes he managed to dodge
just in time but the axe still cleaved
off a chunk of his hair as it passed
abel could see the one who threw it
standing at the entrance to the bar it
was the blood fiend power who made the
axe out of her own blood standing next
to her were denji and aki denji wielding
an axe and aki stoically observing damn
miss makima promised we'd do karaoke at
this bar if i beat you dungy said you're
going down for this abel smiled and
pulled out another pair of blades
finally he roared warriors who fight the
old-fashioned way i feared the years had
stolen you all from me
power stepped forward producing another
blood axe from nowhere she yelled
tremble in fear abel
tis i
your arch nemesis
the mighty power
abel had literally never seen her before
in his thousands of years of life but he
appreciated that these warriors were at
least able to match his level of drama
as far as he was concerned the fight was
on but even abel didn't know the level
of fighting he was getting in for here
as he charged forward the trio split
immediately surrounding him good tactics
abel thought to himself already this was
promising hockey who had remained quiet
up to this point attacked first he drew
a tetano knife from his suit jacket and
slashed at abel with impressive speed
but unlike three of the other combatants
in this situation aki was only human
which gave him a serious disadvantage
able decided it would be best to put him
out of commission first with a quick and
brutal kick to the chest aki was thrown
against the wall with the majority of
his ribs broken revved up by his own
bloodlust abel turned to denji in power
and grinned like a maniac this was
already the most fun he'd had in a long
time who are these people doesn't matter
he thought they'll be dead soon anyway
while abel was still locked in thought
power pulled out a comically large
hammer made out of her own blood and
brought it down towards abel he was
surprised by the sudden attack did this
girl have the same weapon producing
powers as him this just keeps getting
more interesting
tis the end abel
power screamed as the hammer came down
you have once again been defeated by the
mighty power
again just to clarify these two had
never met each other but it was already
too late abel punched upwards his
clenched fist colliding with the hammer
he hit it with such terrifying force
that power's bloodhammer shattered
against his knuckles in that same
instant abel noticed denji running at
him with an axe from behind abel
produced another obsidian dagger and
threw it into denji's forehead dropping
him to the ground immediately pathetic
power tried to produce another weapon
but she used up too much blood already
before she had a chance to make anything
substantial abel sprung forwards with
terrifying speed trying to land a
killing blow but even weakened power was
freakishly fast she was able to dodge
his blow and kick him in the ribs
momentarily stunning him of course she
took the time to gloat putting her hands
on her hips and laughing victoriously
need a second to catch your breath
abel it is to be expected
none can keep up with me she grandiously
announced
perhaps you should just
give up
and agree to become my servant
i might even teach you a thing or two
about fighting
suddenly abel was standing right in
front of her squeezing her throat with
his iron grip he smiled flashing teeth
and said if you want to kill
kill
don't talk with a surprisingly minimal
amount of strength he squeezed and heard
a crunch from power's neck he dropped
her limp body to the ground lucky for
power able wasn't aware that a fiend
like power can survive an injury like
this as long as she's fed some more
blood instead he just sighed in
disappointment is that all you weaklings
have to offer he bellowed aki barely
conscious after being kicked against the
wall remained just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a powerful
beast known as the fox devil he twists
his hands into a strange gesture and
whispers the word com before falling
unconscious but that's still enough
suddenly a gigantic demonic fox claw
burst through the wall of the bar
spraying dust and rubble everywhere abel
was definitely not expecting that he
dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him often barely missing him for its
last strike it lunged forward and raked
four claw marks across his chest abel
was shocked by the sudden pain it felt
fantastic he pulled a long obsidian
spear out of one of his pocket
dimensions and forced it down through
the fox devil's paw and into the ground
pinning it in place after a moment of
thrashing the claw dissipated into smoke
lending abel another victory though even
he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been was
that it had he gained total victory once
more just like he so often did these
days he was about to take pity on
himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch then she asked abel
grinned he liked this kid challenge me
child abel said well
since you asked denji smirked then she
reached into his shirt and grabbed the
ripcord emerging from his chest it was
time to go into overdrive on this thing
he gave it a mighty yank and like the
rev of a chainsaw the madness began
dengi transformed giant blades emerging
from his arms and his head transformed
into a toothy sawblade nightmare he gave
a mechanical roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just dengy anymore this was
chainsaw man now this
able thought feeling his adrenaline
spike is more like it following dengi's
lead abel reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he'd only
previously used against the mighty hard
to destroy reptile
scp-682 the chainsaw claymore a huge
two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting shredding teeth of a chainsaw
ever circulating around it it was time
for chainsaw versus chainsaw what the
hell are you waiting for
chainsaw man lord are we going to stand
around all day are we going to fight
abel couldn't have said it better
himself the two charged at one another
at lightning speeds chainsaw clashing
against chain's sword the sheer force of
the contact was enough to send a
shockwave blasting through the bar it
rapidly became a power struggle each of
them trying hard to force their
chainsaws out of the stalemate realizing
that this time he perhaps couldn't win
with raw strength abel back flipped away
to reassess his options but jane saw man
had no intention of giving able time to
think about it he darted towards abel
with the weight and momentum of a
runaway freight train if abel hadn't
raised his claymore to perry he would
have been shredded to pieces by the
devil saws in an instant instead the two
of them rocketed out of the nearby wall
in a cascade of debris causing everyone
on the outside street to run for their
lives the two quickly stood from the
stumble the two quickly stood up
catching their breath impressive abel
said you're much better than the others
instead of replying denji briefly
retracted his armed chainsaws and
grabbed a nearby parked car throwing it
directly at abel abel reacted quickly
cleaving the car in half with his
claymore and charging for chainsaw man
again just before abel could land a
lethal strike chainsaw man deployed his
chainsaws again blocking the blow abel
sped around him trying to strike again
and again but chainsaw man blocked every
strike with stunning efficacy abel was
astonished few had ever been able to go
toe to toe with him like this before he
could feel his heart pounding gloriously
in his chest he would give dengi a
warrior's death with a furious yell abel
brought down the chainsaw claymore for a
devastating vertical strike but chainsaw
man was ready he arranged his arm
chainsaws in a cross formation like a
giant pair of scissors and caught abel's
chain sword between them chainsaw man
pulled his arms in opposite directions
slicing abel's mighty sword in half the
immortal swordsman skidded backwards to
avoid the fallout producing two smaller
blades immediately this chainsaw man
just kept exceeding expectations didn't
he abel would need to change tactics if
he wanted to win this one chainsaw man
was impressed by the speed and tenacity
of his foe for someone who apparently
wasn't even a devil abel sure packed a
hell of a punch did he ever run out of
those damned weapons though attempting
to answer chainsaw man's question for
him abel began running around his flank
rapidly producing and throwing blades
and axes in a startling volley chainsaw
man was able to use his chainsaw arms
and face to block most of them but not
all of them several daggers and small
throwing axes splattered into the tender
flesh of chainsaw man's chest abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
abel decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he sent dengy flying down the street
carving a rut into the concrete beneath
him but abel wasn't done while chainsaw
man was still trying to recover abel
leaped onto him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace the
strikes were so brutal they shook the
earth and sent cracks across the
surrounding ground then abel stopped he
realized for a moment that he was
letting his bloodlust get the better of
him this was dishonorable where would be
the fun in beating this boy to death
while he lay on the ground and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents
he's had in quite some time no that
would not do it all he'd give him one
more chance on your feet boy abel said
you fight well get up and carry on i
won't let a beast as rare as you die
like a common dog rise and fight me and
chainsaw man did as he was told abel was
shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as chainsaw man burst up
through it all his swords at the ready
the mace was thrown from abel's hands as
chainsaw men launched up towards him all
metal teeth and fury luckily for abel he
pulled out a battle axe just in time to
block the flurry of brutal strikes from
the patron saint of chainsaws now this
was a fight even musashi would be proud
of yes boy yes abel yelled this is true
combat chainsaw man replied with the
swing of his blades which abel was
nearly able to dodge the two finally
landed back down on the ground and abel
was fast enough to bury his battle axe
and chainsaw man's shoulder before the
devil could return a blow to abel the
anomalous swordsman pulled out a pair of
his favorite swords and locked chainsaw
man's arms in place jane saw man was
undeniably incredibly powerful but it
looked like abel's superior experience
and tactics might save him this time
what the hell are you chainsaw man lord
you've been a worthy opponent boy those
are few and far between mabel said i'll
remember you for this but before abel
could execute a killing blow he felt a
blood-red throwing axe stick into his
back abel winced in pain to see power
and aki about 30 feet behind him power
was propping aki up he donated some of
his blood to bring her back to life and
she was just as delusionally cocky as
ever abel was about to say something but
he already made a fatal mistake letting
his guard down before another word could
pass the cursed warrior's lips one of
chainsaw man's armed chainsaws passed
directly through his heart tearing it
apart with enable's chest it was a
sudden and decisive killing blow
chainsaw man pulled his saw back out of
abel's chest stained with the deadly
anomaly's blood abel collapsed to the
ground wheezing and bleeding profusely
from the hole in his chest but strangely
as power akki and chainsaw man converged
around him they realized he was smiling
thank you
abel said and died yet again with the
battle won like an incredible hulk made
of metal chain saw man transformed back
into dengy the trio stood around abel's
corpse deeply confused as to what had
just happened if this was the kind of
thing the scp foundation normally dealt
with they all silently agreed that
perhaps it would be better not to get
involved with them in the future except
power of course who said
you two should be thanking me for
defeating him
you both owe me drinks for this
hundreds of miles away in a black
sarcophagus deep underwater surrounded
by professional scp foundation divers
abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remain sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held were the opponents and for
abel that was everything now go check
out could scp-682 be contained in the
back rooms and scp-096 versus siren head
for more deranged out-of-universe
crossovers from the scp foundation